did you know your entire life is just
30,000 days if you're 30 you've already
burned through 11,000 time isn't
slipping away it's sprinting but what if
you could slow it
down this video reveals why your brain
makes years disappear as you age and the
shocking trick to make time expand again
how new experiences literally rewire
your perception take different routes
talk to strangers break routines here's
the deathbed test will you care about
that extra hour at work or the moment
stolen from loved ones successful people
use the two list strategy weapon against
busy work relationships aren't built on
grand gestures a text a shared struggle
a remembered detail and career gold it's
not in your comfort zone it's One Step
Beyond jungle gyms beat ladders every
time your biggest mistake thinking
morning you and evening you are the same
person Health isn't about living longer
it's about living Fuller 10 push-ups now
beat two hours at the gym someday life
design isn't a plan it's experiments
tiny changes today create Avalanches
tomorrow your 30,000 days start now